you know we have this very childish way
of talking about sex we go hey it's bang
o'clock
four o'clock is going to be bang o'clock
gary said he tried
bang a clock at four o'clock like what
happened you said to mary hey there's
this thing going on right
she knows what bang o'clock is i said
they're doing this really cool thing
where they're like doing bang a clock
today before and they thought it would
be
like fun if everybody did it you know it
would be really cool
and she goes you're usually in a meeting
at four i go i can move some stuff
around and she just laughed and walked
away
wow oh dear you know
she made a face too she's like come on
give me a break like but once
but why not like why not everyone bang
it four o'clock it would have been fun
yeah no i get the fun of it yeah i'll do
bang o'clock at two in the morning if
that's what you're saying right what
about like healing the world one load at
a time
i mean seriously king of all blacks
wants to say good morning go ahead king
no disrespect to gary i love gary but i
don't think his wife
is sexually attracted to him anymore
you know i mean listen he's a fun guy
but you know
he needs like this is his air time is
his oxygen so
he hears something and he just makes up
a ridiculous premise so he can get on
but you know listen our life is plenty
good john hein and his wife debbie i
think they have more sex than gary and
mary
john hein you wouldn't believe it yeah i
think he is very sexual with her being
real honest
why would john han's wife
like why is she attracted to him king
i talked to chris wilding about this who
is a gay man he believes john hein is
very well hung like he's got a big thick
[ __ ]
no that could be that would be part of
it but gary
i don't think gary's home i don't
understand you actually
i'm fine i've seen gary gary's very
thick
he's got like a good i'm good he's got a
big beer can [ __ ]
all right so so if he so if he's so sick
then why does his wife laugh at all you
think that two people can't be in love
and you know that no just based on looks
no no you said
you said you can't understand the
attraction between john and his wife
you can't understand why john's wife
loves him john's a great guy
king you don't understand john is a
really good guy
i didn't say that i did
[Laughter]
i want to tell king something look
clearly gary and i are complete charity
cases we know how lucky we are
we know we both know how better looking
our wives are than we
are but somehow someway we've managed to
have a couple
kids stay together for a long time and
have a pretty great relationship and
that's both physical
and also you know inside and outside the
[Music]
bedroom
you